christine zum einkaufen zuerst den
buchladen und dann noch ein bisschen
gemüse die waren kauft das boot endlich
anleihen ist doch viel praktischer
funktionen internetshopping beginne die
ganzen kleinen leben ging oder kaputt da
mache ich nicht mit
hier ist mittlerweile argo online stehen
begrüßt mich langsam bitte hügel runter
mit einem online scheiße geht es zum
einkauf und zwar leibhaftig analog im
internet e card für das wird sie niemals
durchsetzen
[Musik]
hallo herr oder
der minister selbst tragen
endlich mal neue jacke
oder sehr schneider sie auch
[Musik]
fürs team
christine ich stecke im treppenhaus fest
und weiter ja du sagt br maxl er soll 25
kartoffeln und einem bunt gelbe rüben
bestellen
logisch online wo sonst was man in rom
kommt keine ahnung vielleicht eine
stunde zwei stunden
wenn's gut geht
[Musik]
[Applaus]